let's go to the voicemails you can call
me
anytime
and many do call at very strange times
during which i'm typically sleeping at
219 to david p
um i do have 600 voicemails to triage
from the long weekend i'm working on it
but here is one
asking about whether i speak an
additional language take a listen to
this
hi david um hello sir
um i was wondering whether or not uh
your family speaks judeo espanol or
ladino uh this is a dying surprise
language uh i myself am a society jew
i was wondering whether or not your
family especially because they speak
spanish
um is is a family that speaks this i'm
the first in my family in 500 years to
not speak it fluently
my family are turkish shoes
which most people don't know exists but
there is a population of jewish folks in
turkey
and we were accepted by uh sultan beiji
ii
after the inquisition um he famously
told queen isabella and king ferdinand
uh what you consider to be garbage we
consider to be treasure and accepted by
family
um okay you know um my family is not
sephardic and we do not speak ladino
um or judeo-spanish i
yeah be being ashkenazi and being born
in argentina um
we just spoke spanish that's it but a
fascinating language a fascinating
language and uh i can i'm glad to give a
list of the languages i don't speak it
would just be a very very long list
um
and it would make for a pretty boring
show but no fascinating history to the
language don't speak a word of it
although i don't know how similar it is
to spanish maybe it's sort of like with
portuguese or some of the spanish
dialects where it just sounds or italian
or french where it sounds similar enough
that i could understand it all right we
have a tremendous bonus show for you
today
portland is set to vote on banning
travel from texas this would be
sort of a retaliation to the new texas
abortion law
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
number two
a judge has ruled
that an ohio hospital cannot be forced
to give patients ivermectin period
and number three
el salvador has become sort of the first
bitcoin nation they have now bought for
national as part of their national
reserves i guess is the word to use
they have bought i think it's 200
bitcoin
what does this mean what are the pros
and cons could we see more countries do
it is this crazy does it make any sense
we will discuss that on today's bonus
show how do you access the bonus show
very easy
you sign up at joinpakman.com it's that
simple you sign up and within 30 seconds
you could be listening to the bonus show
if you already have an account on
patreon or want to make one for whatever
reason you might prefer it you can also
access the bonus show by making a pledge
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow of at
least five bucks a month we will see
everybody then or if not on tomorrow's
show